c'est encore à l'étape de prototypes en
3d un projet qui ne sera pas réalisé
avant plusieurs mois mais la capsule
flottante ipulp d'une équipe d'étudiants
de polytechnique prend forme
on appelle ces microcapsules donc c'est
il ya personne qui votent dans la
capsule c'est assez petit mais c'est le
format qui est la plupart des équipes
dans le monde utilisent et donc c'est
vraiment le seul but c'est vraiment de
pousser la technologie au maximum
l'équipe de polytechnique montréal
composé d'une cinquantaine d'étudiants
espère participer à la prochaine édition
de l'ipl ou pas de compétition qui
devrait avoir lieu à l'été 2022 en
californie et où l'on présente les
meilleurs prototypes harper loupe en
amérique et ce moteur là on espère que
en fait la capsule va aller à plus de
300 km heure sur une distance d'environ
un kilomètre
la technologie de trains a un peu loupé
a été popularisé par le milliardaire
américain et le masque liane dizaine
d'années le principe utilisé la
propulsion électromagnétiques pour faire
léviter une capsule de passagers aidé à
propulser à très grande vitesse
plus de mille kilomètres à l'heure d'un
vieux tube dépressurisée c'est une
alternative durable qui est écologique
parce que c'est 100 % électrique et donc
ça pourrait permettre des voyages entre
entrées des villes les distances
interurbaines rapidement mais en
réduisant considérablement l'impact
environnemental des transports pour les
étudiants de polytechnique développé un
prototype de triple loop est une tâche
très complexe mais à moyen terme il
espère encourager le développement d'un
premier modèle québécois
c'est une technologie qui est nouvelle
donc un peu beaucoup de littérature de
recherche qui a été fait sur cette
technologie donc on doit tout apprendre
même
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal